♪[music]♪
- We are the paradoxical ape, bi-pedal,
naked, large brain, long the master of
fire, tools and language, but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable yet filled with optimism. We
grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge. We
empathize and deceive. We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity of humans
like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [David] The basic problem I address here
is one of how did languages come to do
what they do in terms of taking small
meaningless units and combining them to
make meaningful words. So using some
English examples: sat, sit, sad. Each time
I change one of the sounds we get a
different word. Sat, bat, fat, same thing.
So what I'm going to argue for is that
this is a commentatorial system and by
looking at sign language evidence, we can
see what things are like in some ways
before such a system evolves and get some
clues about how such a system evolves.
I'm going to be using primarily data from
American Sign Language and a lot of people
when they see signs they say, "Oh, it's
all iconic." And a lot of the signs look
iconic, i.e.that you could guess the
meaning from seeing the sign. So, for
example, drink, bird, house, all of those
you can get a pretty good idea of the
meaning from the sign itself.
However, those look like. . . they look
like gestures. You're gesturing something
about the meaning. But really in a mature
sign language like American Sign Language,
it has the same type of combinatoriality
within the word that I illustrated with
those examples from English.
And the signs consist of smaller parts
combined in different ways to produce
different signs with different meanings.
To find out what these smaller parts are
we have to find examples of signs that
differ in only one respect. And I'm going
to show you some examples now where we can
identify the smaller parts of the signs by
comparing signs that differ in only one
respect. And at the same time be
illustrating a second point that in most
you cases you cannot guess the meaning
from seeing the sign if you don't already
know the language. So, first I'll show
some signs that differ only in handshake
versus, versus.
And unless you know the language you
probably don't know that this means
change, this means translate, and this
means interpret. Similarly, bird which I
showed you, print or publish, 20. These
show that the place of articulation,
there'll be a lot of that later, makes a
difference. So bird articulated at the
edge of the lip, print or publish on the
other hand.
And signs can differ only in movement,
name, short, knife, egg.
All of those I don't think you would guess
the meaning from seeing them the first
time and illustrate how signs can differ
in movement. And we'll concentrate on
these three things. So each sign consists
of a hand shape, a place of articulation,
and a movement. There's also sometimes
orientation plays a role. I will set those
cases aside since they won't be essential
to the points that are made here.
Each sign language has an inventory of
hand shapes, places of articulation, and
movements, and it's a combinatorial
phonological system that puts them
together yielding different signs with
different meanings. Some signs are fully
iconic. So bird, all of its smaller parts
which I'll call formatives, all of its
formatives contribute to the iconicity.
The hand shape is L, the movement: the
index touches the thumb twice, place of
articulation, POA, is at the edge of the
lip.
And all three of those contribute to the
iconicity and bird shares hand shape and
movement as I showed you before with
print/publish, or 20. And the place of
articulation is the same as in drink or in
famous also at the edge of the lips.
So bird is fully iconic, all of these
contribute to the iconicity. Some signs
are partially iconic and then an example
of that is heart one. I'll be talking
altogether about two signs, heart. This is
an older form, later we'll see a newer
form. So that is this heart, very iconic.
The movement: a heart shape. Place of
articulation, left side of chest about
where the heart is located.
But there is an arbitrary element, the
hand shape is this open eight hand shape
which has nothing to do with heart. It's
completely arbitrary. Some signers
interprets the heart shape the way I've
been doing it more or less the heart shape
you see on Valentines, for some it's an
oval, for some it's a circle.
An important distinction throughout this
talk is the distinction between gestures
and signs. And so, I've coined a notation
here to keep them different. On the left
is a gesture. Trace a heart shape over
region of the heart which could be done
with any finger or fingers or combination
as opposed to the sign. So the gesture is
in these double angled brackets, a sign
has these three formatives and each of
those is enclosed in square brackets. Very
important here is the gestural hypothesis
that iconic signs evolved from holistic
gestures. So that the sign heart on the
right evolved from the gesture on the
left. And a piece of evidence for that, if
that is the case that the sign heart one
evolved from the gesture heart, this
hypothesis makes a prediction that early
on there would have been variation in the
finger or fingers used to trace the heart
shape since that hand shape plays no role
in the gesture itself which is just trace
the heart shape.
It doesn't say anything about which finger
or fingers. And in fact there is evidence
that that is correct, that there was
variation early on. I'm indebted to
Brandon Scates for bringing to my
attention that an 1884 book, "Deaf mutes
describe a small surface over heart and
pointing downwards," saying nothing about
which finger or fingers. And Higgins,
1923, "Right index points to heart or
right thumb and index trace shape of heart
in region of heart or both index tips
trace shape of heart." And notice that
none of these are the open eight hand
shape used for heart in ASL.
So this is one kind of evidence for the
gestural origin of the sign heart. Now,
what distinguishes one sign from another?
And I'm going to show you two signs now
that differ only in place of articulation.
And this one means Canada, this one means
Yom Kippur.
And the only difference is whether I do it
at the place of articulation on my right
side here of the chest or the left side.
Okay. Now, for those of you who do not
know ASL, I'm going to do a sign and you
tell me which it means. Canada or Yom
Kippur?
How many say Canada? How many say Yom
Kippur? Okay. It looks about evenly split
to the extent I can see.
Well, actually this means Canada, but
before I said this means Canada and this
means Yom Kippur, why doesn't this mean
Yom Kippur? I'm doing it with my left
hand. Before, I did it with my right hand.
What this shows is that the relevant
distinction is not between right and left
on the chest. And I'll introduce the terms
ipsilateral. This is Latin, ipsi is same,
lateral is side. An ipsilateral sign or
sign's place of articulation is on the
same side as the articulating hand.
Contralateral signs are articulated on the
opposite side. So Canada, ipsilateral and
I'm right-handed. This is Canada, this is
Yom Kippur. A left-handed person, this is
Canada, this is Yom Kippur. The crucial
thing is whether it's ipsilateral or
contralateral. Now, let's go back to heart
and I'm going to show you the other sign
for heart which I'm right-handed, so this
is heart. And that seems like the place of
articulation is iconically motivated. But
how would have a left hander sign heart?
Why? Because it's contralateral. I'm
right-handed I sign it over here where the
heart is located more or less. But for a
left hander, it's also contralateral so we
sign over here.
So this is an important fact and this
illustrates the major transformation that
has taken place in what I'm talking about
today. Namely that the formal
characterization of place of articulation
as either ipsilateral or contralateral
trumps the iconicity. These things started
out iconic with the movement being iconic,
the place of articulation where the heart
is located.
But once they evolve from gestures to
signs, we now have a system where the
formal properties of the signs take over
and trump the original iconic motivation
of the form coming from the original
iconic gesture. This gives us a way of
seeing formal properties of signs as
opposed to the gestures from which they
derive. And right and left have no place,
but ipsilateral, contralateral are
essential. So let me show you some other
signs now where you can see the same
thing. So direction of movement is either
ipsilateral or contralateral. So I'll show
you the signs for right and left. When I
sign right, my hand moves to the right.
When I sign left, my hand moves to the
left. But really, when I sign right, my
hand is moving in the ipsilateral
direction and when I sign left my hand is
moving in the contralateral direction. So,
when a left-handed person signs right, the
hand moves in the ipsilateral direction
which is to the left.
And when a left-handed person signs left,
the hand moves in the contralateral
direction which is to the right. This
shows very clearly that what's relevant is
the formal properties of the place of
articulation, not the original iconic
motivation which you see in the
right-handed signing but the left-handed
signing turns that on its head. Also, I
want to dispel any idea you might have
gotten that the gestural source of
particular signs might only have been in
the distant past and also that there's any
physical difference necessarily between
gestures and signs.
So the sign Yom Kippur that I've been
illustrating has a gestural source which
is this, which is physically exactly the
same as the sign. It's done in the
synagogue service on Yom Kippur. There's a
prayer, it's a communal confession of
various kinds of sins. Each type of sin,
as it's mentioned, the worshipers go like
this. What do the left handers do? This is
the gesture that is the source of the sign
Yom Kippur, physically identical to it.
For left handers in the synagogue service,
it goes to the place where the heart is
located which is here on the left side.
But when they sign the sign Yom Kippur
which is evolved from that gesture, it's
on the opposite side, the contralateral
side because Yom Kippur is a contralateral
sign.
Okay. So this difference between gestures
and signs is the key thing. The signs have
certain formal properties. They evolved
from gestures, but once they have these
formal properties they can turn out quite
differently. And we can generalize, and
some of the other papers have talked about
this, Mark Aranoff and Carol Padden's just
before this. A more general gestural
hypothesis that sign languages have their
earliest stages in gestural communication
and have evolved from that to current sign
languages.
And a very great confirmation of this is
the Al-Sayyid Bedouin sign language that
Mark Aranoff just mentioned in his
presentation where he and three others
have been studying this new Bedouin sign
language in Southern Israel which does not
have a combinatorial system, a
combinatorial phonological system putting
parts together as we saw here. Okay, one
last point. Comparative cross-species
evidence from language experiments with
chimpanzees. These are chimpanzees that
people signed with for years and years.
Rivas did 22 hours of video tape and
eliminated all cases where they just
repeated what the human had signed within
the previous five seconds.
Here's the number of different signs each
of these chimps produced and their four
most frequent signs accounted for 58%,
45%, etc.of their total output. The main
thing is after years of this, why is their
vocabulary so small? The explanation: that
chimps learn no signs at all, only a small
set of holistic gestures. And a deeper
explanation for that is that they don't
have the combinatorial abilities that
humans have to have a combinatorial system
putting meaningful words or signs together
from smaller units. This suggests strongly
that these combinatorial abilities of
humans developed after the split between
the human and chimpanzee lineages. Thank
you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪